katia bonjour qu'est ce qu'il faut
attendre de ces auditions aujourd'hui du
côté de l'assemblée nationale et elles
vont tenter de faire la lumière sur
d'éventuelles pressions dans le cadre de
la sphère fillon donc aujourd'hui c'est
la procureur général de paris catherine
champrenault comme vous le disiez qui va
être entendu pourquoi parceque ils
viennent ou let qui est l'ancienne
patronne du parquet financier avait
parlé d'une énorme pression dans le
cadre de cette enquête
cette enquête évidemment qui était très
médiatisé et en fait elle parlait d'une
énorme pression qui consistait en de
très très nombreuses demandes et elle
s'est sentie disette est étroitement
contrôlée alors est-ce qu'il pouvait
s'agir d'une pression politique c'est
pourquoi la une polémique a enflé il
n'en fallait pas plus pour que les
avocats de françois fillon demandent des
éclaircissements demande la réouverture
des débats ce qui leur a été refusé
et depuis il ya nulle et est un peu
revenu sur ses propos elle a expliqué
qu'il ne s'agissait pas de pression
politique mais de pressions
hiérarchiques et que cela portait
uniquement sur la procédure elle
penchait pour l'ouverture d'une enquête
préliminaire tandis que catherine
champrenault souhaitait une information
judiciaire et catherine champrenault
évidemment a réagi avant d'être entendu
aujourd'hui elle a nié toute pression de
quelque nature que ce soit selon elle l
a fait savoir qu'elle n'avait fait que
veiller à l'application de la loi et au
bon fonctionnement des parcs et placé
sous son autorité elle n'avait fait que
préconisé l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire et c'est une procédure qui
est conforme à la loi
merci katia pique nique en direct donc
de l'assemblée nationale